first on CBS this morning a glimpse at
the largest Tyrannosaurus Rex ever to
have roamed the earth
this massive creature named Scottie
weighed an estimated 20,000 pounds
that's about eight thousand pounds more
than the average t-rex it will soon go
on display at the Royal Saskatchewan
Museum in Canada Jamie yuccas got the
first look Jamie good morning good
morning drum roll please it's time for
the big reveal meet Scottie it was found
in 1991 but won't go on full display
until later this week now researchers
don't know is that a boy is it a girl
the reason for the name Scottie is
because the only spirit they had on hand
at the time of the discovery was scotch
it's the biggest baddest dinosaur known
to man the Tyrannosaurus Rex around 67
million years ago they roamed the earth
and a little more recently on the big
screen
then there's Scotty the largest of them
all who was found here in the Frenchman
River Valley in Canada the mecca of
dinosaur stomping grounds Scotty was
found in this valley of the Badlands
back in the early 1990s it took almost a
decade to pull it all out of the ground
and it wasn't until recently that
scientists realized just how big it was
it's never like what you see depicted in
Jurassic Park right where you're out
there in the Badlands and you're just
brushing the dust the sand off of a
wonderfully complete 100 percent bear
articulated skeleton Scott Persons was
at the original dig site and led the
team reconstructing Scotty he says its
bones reveal Scotty had a tough ride
back in Mesozoic times
Scotty lived a hard-knock life it's got
evidence of a broken jaw of an impacted
tooth it's got a section of its tail
where the vertebrae seem to have been
compressed possibly from the bite of
another Taranis or these are all
injuries not from a single moment in
Scotty's life but from a continued life
of a lot of lumps the thigh bone of
Scotty is here Tim to Carrick was there
too he showed us some of Scotty's actual
bones in the t-rex Discovery Center so
this is just one back bone yeah can I
hold it you can just you know my
goodness awake to it
there is definitely weight to it just
how much did it weigh paleontologists
believe Scotty weighed nearly 20,000
pounds or about as much as six and a
half Volkswagen Beetles so Scotty was
the size of a school bus her city bus
Scotty is such a behemoth it edged out
sue the famous t-rex at the Field Museum
of Natural History in Chicago who is 40
feet long and weighed more than 18,000
pounds as our material was being
prepared I knew it was something big Wes
long spent more than 10 years pulling
Scotty from the ground and helped
reconstruct the carnivorous King when
you saw those bones being uncovered what
went through your mind you're in awe of
what you're uncovering like you'd be
zipping away with your air hammer and
all of a sudden a piece of rock would
fly off and there's like a beautiful
tooth there and it's just like wow this
thing it's huge
massive scientists found they had about
65% of the skeleton intact including the
skull the lower jaw vertebrae from the
neck back and tail and parts of the hips
leg and shoulder all of the parts that
make up this astonishing site people
from all over the world are coming to
see why do people love the t-rex so much
well it's just had that long history
even in pop culture as like being the
big bad dinosaur and and it's just that
when the people can really identify with
and it's just been a popular dinosaur
like throughout history Friday is the
day the public will be able to come in
here and see it scottie by the way has
other claims to fame as well for
instance it likely reached its 30th
birthday making it the longest living
t-rex in history Nora
Wow Jamie yuccas in Canada
that's terrific I'm fascinated by Scott
persons who's all his name is also Scott
who led the dig I'm thinking he likes
Indiana Jones I know what you're having
he's really gonna do his job I like it
he's right out of central casting hence
I like it yeah Jamie there next to the
t-rex you got a sense of how really
biggest I still really need a backyard
for that time yeah yeah Jamie does that
do the the display Jamie I still don't
understand I'm sure you said it why you
don't know if it's a boy or girl so they
can't actually look at the DNA of it
that it genetically they can't figure
out the pelvis size is what they
actually look at they think it might be
a girl but they can't say for sure
so that's they have to still do more
research that's why these types of finds
are such a big deal all right Scott
aren't you thank you